Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Heute sprechen wir mit Kai Pahl von Alles außer Sport und mit Christoph Anheuser vom sportmedienblog.de über die Vergabe der TV-Fußballrechte. Die erste Folge des Kurzpasses. Los geht's! Kai, einen schönen guten Abend.
Moin moin aus Hamburg.
Und schön, dass auch du wieder mit dabei bist. Servus, Christoph. Wir sind ja schon ein eingespieltes Team aus dem Tribünengespräch, was wir zu dem Thema Fußball-TV-Rechte gehalten haben. Und heute haben wir die Mammut-Aufgabe vor uns, keine Mammutsendung aus dem hier werden zu lassen. Wir wollen darüber reden, was heute passiert ist. Nämlich, es wurde die Entscheidung getroffen, wie die Fußball-TV-Rechte bepreist sind, von den Spielzeiten 17, 18 bis 20, 21. Und da, lieber Kai, hat sich die Prognose von DFL-Chef Christian Seifert erfüllt. Er hat gesagt, zwischen 1,1 Milliarden und 1,5 Milliarden Euro pro Saison möge man erlösen. Und wir sind jetzt bei 1,16 Milliarden Euro durchschnittlich rausgekommen. Also ein voller Erfolg für die DFL.
Ja, erst mal am unteren Ende des Zielkorridors. Es werden zwar noch zwei Pakete vergeben. Dazu kann man auch das Einige dazu denken. Aber bei diesen beiden Paketen dürfte nicht viel hinzukommen. Um wirklich dann bei den 1,4 bis 1,5 Milliarden Euro pro Saison zu landen, setzt die DFL halt auch noch auf relativ hohe Erlöse im Auslandsbereich. Mal gucken, ob es so kommt. Die Zahlen sind ja nicht sehr transparent, nicht so opak. Im Grunde genommen muss man das fressen, was da sehr gefiltert an die Öffentlichkeit bringt.
Genau das wollen wir jetzt auch in diesem kleinen Kurzpass tun. Ich würde mal sagen, wir versuchen einfach mal alles aus der Brille des Konsumenten zu sehen, also des Fußballfans, und mal anhand dieser Perspektive zu erklären, was sich jetzt verändern wird ab der Saison 2017, 2018. Christoph, die erste große Änderung ist, dass nicht mehr alle Livespiele bei Sky sind.
Exakt, also das war ja schon abzusehen. Es gab ja zwei Optionen, dadurch, dass das Kartellamt ja eingegriffen hatte und gesagt hatte, wir möchten nicht, dass ein, ja alle Spiele exklusiv erwirbt, und es dadurch dieses No Single Buyer-Rule gab, die wir lang und breit im Tribünengespräch erläutert hatten. Kai hat sich dann entschieden, dass es nicht möchte, dass dieses sogenannte Over-the-Top, das reine Internetpaket, auf den Markt kommt, weil es der Auffassung war, dass dieses Paket viel zu attraktiv ist und viel zu sehr dann seinem eigenen Geschäftsmodell schadet. Im Endeffekt ist es dann dazu gekommen, dass ein Paket, das was Kai schon so schön als Restrampe bezeichnet hat, nämlich das Paket A mit den Freitagsspielen im Wesentlichen und so ein bisschen anderen Spielen, dann bei einem anderen Anbieter gelandet ist. Es gab dann im Vorfeld viele Spekulationen, wo es landen würde. Die Spekulationen gingen dann von Telekom, Vodafone hinzu performen und am Ende wurde es dann Eurosport. Im Endeffekt ist es für den Konsumenten, für den Fan mit Sicherheit nicht die allerschlechteste Lösung, weil letztendlich, das ist jetzt auch dadurch, dass Eurosport es schon offiziell bekannt gegeben hat, wie man diese Rechte nutzen möchte, nämlich über Eurosport 2. Führt es dazu, dass man auch weiterhin, solange sich Sky und Eurosport einig sind, dass Eurosport 2 bei Sky ausgestrahlt wird, zumindest über Satt, Kabelbereich ist ein bisschen anders, dass man auch weiterhin nur ein Abo braucht, um alle Spiele zu sehen.
Okay, das heißt Kai, wenn ich jetzt Sky habe und da Eurosport 2 mit enthalten ist, in welchem Paket ist das drin? Im Sportpaket wahrscheinlich dann?
Genau, ja.
Das heißt, ich muss nicht mehr zahlen, wenn es so bleibt, wie es jetzt ist?
Genau, du müsstest nicht mehr zahlen, sofern keine Preissteigungen kommen, etc., Das Ganze wohlgemerkt nur für den Kunden, der Sky wie er Satellit empfängt. Über Kabel sieht, wer die Karten irgendwie da nochmal komplett neu mischt, da kommt es dann wirklich auf die einzelnen Kabelnitzer an, wie da bzw. in welchen Paketen dann Eurosport 2 drin ist. Das lässt sich, glaube ich, nicht mehr so einfach aufdröseln.
Ist Eurosport 2 denn überhaupt überall zu empfangen über Kabel und Satellit oder gibt es da vielleicht sogar noch weiße Flecken auf der Deutschlandkarte?
Weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht. Was mir aufgefallen ist jetzt insgesamt bei der Bewerbung von Eurosport, von diesem erworbenen Rechtepaket, ist, dass im Grunde genommen gleichberechtigt auch immer der Eurosport-Player genannt wird, als Vermeidungspartform, also das Online-Angebot, Bezahlangebot von Eurosport, was, glaube ich, derzeit, keine Ahnung, größt in Ordnung fünf oder sechs Euro im Monat kostet. Und die beiden Eurosport-Kanäle enthält plus zusätzliche Kanäle für andere Tennisplätze oder Kameraperspektiven bei der MotoGP etc. oder auch Squash-Turniere werden dort gezeigt, die so im Fernsehen zum Beispiel nur als Zusammenfassung laufen oder ähnliches. Ob es bei diesem Preis bleiben wird, wenn man die Freitagsspiele mit rein nimmt, ab Sommer 2017 wird man abwarten müssen.
Okay, ist ja auch noch ein bisschen Zeit. Das bedeutet, fassen wir kurz nochmal zusammen, Christoph, wir werden die Freitagsspiele nur auf Eurosport 2 sehen können. Die 13.30-Spiele, die es am Sonntag geben wird, immer dann, wenn Europa-Liga, also viele Bundesligisten in der Europa-Liga antreten, und ebenso die Montagsspiele, die es manchmal geben wird, ich glaube fünf an der Zahl maximal, sowie die Relegation zur Bundesliga und zweiter Bundesliga und den Supercup. Das verschwindet jetzt alles ins PayTV, war ja nicht alles bisher dort.
Also der Supercup ist nicht exklusiv, den gibt es auch meines Wissens im FreeTV, der ist auch in dem Paket H, das das CDF erworben hat. Aber mit den Freitagsspielen bis halt auf die drei Spiele, die auch in dem Paket H sind, am 1., am 17. und am 18. Spieltag, die sind exklusiv bei EuroSport, genauso wie die Relegation hin- und Rückspiele zwischen der ersten und der zweiten Liga.
Und das sollte man vielleicht nochmal betonen, dass diese Relegation-Spiele zwischen der ersten und der zweiten Liga pay-TV-only sind, ist eine der Neuerungen bei dieser Ausschreibung. Was man vielleicht auch erwähnen sollte, mein Eindruck aus den Formulierungen, die die DFL immer gewählt hat, bei der Beschreibung der Montags- und Sonntags-Spiele dieser zehn Stück, die es für Europapokal-Teilnehmer geben kann, ist, dass sie zeitlich nicht zwingend zu fix sind. Rein schriftlich sieht es aus, als würde es bis zu fünf Spiele am Montag 20.30 Uhr geben und bis zu fünf Spiele Sonntag 13.30 Uhr. Aber gerade bei den Sonntags-Spielen hatte ich den Eindruck, dass man sich auch die Option offen hält, die Dinge auf Sonntag 18 Uhr zu verfrachten, parallel zum normalen Sonntag-18-Uhr-Spiel.
Was ja aber dann bedeuten würde, ich könnte das gar nicht mehr in einer Konferenz gleichzeitig sehen. Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe. Oder wenn es parallel läuft zu einem Spiel, das bei Sky exklusiv läuft?
Das wäre so der Fall, aber wie gesagt, es ist erst mal nur eine Hintertür. Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass diese Anschlusszeiten der zehn Spiele wirklich in Stein gemeißelt sind. Ob es immer noch ein realistisches Szenario ist, dass am Sonntag um 18 Uhr dann zwei Spiele stattfinden, als auf Orgelsport und als auf Sky, wird man sehen müssen.
Ich denke, das war auch mehr so eine Hintertür dafür, dass falls das Paket A, also mit den Freitagsspielen und den vereinzelten Sonntagsspielen in derselben Hand gelandet wäre, wie das Paket E mit den anderen Sonntagsspielen, dass dann ein möglicher Rechteinhaber gesagt hätte, ich möchte aber lieber hier Konferenzen zeigen, anstatt jetzt hier drei Spiele am Stück. Ich denke, das war mehr so der Hintergrund. Ich denke, es ist nicht so, dass man da jetzt großartig rumlavieren möchte oder die Spiele hin und her schieben möchte.
Ja, ich denke, man wird halt natürlich auch erst mal diese Sonntags 13.30 Uhr Anstoßzeit erst mal austesten müssen, was die Bundesliga angeht, die dann ja auch in Konkurrenz zur zweiten Liga stattfinden wird. Was springt an Einschaltquote dann für den Sender in diesem Fall Eurosport raus oder macht es zum Beispiel die zweite Liga von Sky komplett kaputt?
Zur zweiten Liga will ich noch kommen. Lasst uns mal erst noch bei der ersten Liga bleiben. Also ich denke, wir haben jetzt ganz gut umrissen, welche Spiele nicht mehr bei Sky sind. Und ansonsten ist es relativ einfach. Man kann sagen, den kompletten Rest hat sich Sky gesichert und noch ein bisschen mehr als bisher, Kai. Und jetzt kommen wir dann auch zur zweiten Liga.
Genau, das ist letztendlich eine weitere Neuerung, die es bei dieser Ausschraubung gegeben hat. Das Montagsspiel um 20.30 Uhr der zweiten Liga ist in einem Paket ausgeschrieben worden, das offen sowohl für Pay-TV-Anbieter als auch Free-TV-Anbieter war. Aber es war halt nur ein Paket. Bislang war das Montagsspiel ja auf zwei Plattformen zu sehen, weil es eben in zwei Paketen drin war. Nämlich im Pay-TV bei Sky und bei Sport1 dann im Free-TV. Dies wird ab Sommer 2017 nicht mehr der Fall sein. Das Montagsspiel der 2. Liga wird ausschließlich im Pay-TV bei Sky zu sehen sein, was diverse Kollateralschäden hat. Sky hat sich damit ein weiteres Exklusivrecht gesichert. Sport1 hat damit ein wichtiges Recht verloren, weil das Montagsspiel der 2. Liga immerhin für Roundabout eine Million Zuschauer immer wieder gut war. Und die 2. Liga verliert natürlich auch im Free-TV eine Präsenz, was gegenüber den Sponsoren und der Bandenwerbung auch ein relativ wichtiger Punkt ist. Eine Million Zuschauer pro Woche, die ein Spiel sozusagen weniger zu sehen bekommen, die Banden nicht zu sehen bekommen und die Trikotsponsoren nicht zu sehen bekommen. Da bin ich gespannt, ob das bei der noch ausstehenden Diskussion über die TV-Gelderverteilung zwischen Bundesliga und 2. Liga auch noch so ein Knackpunkt werden wird.
Okay, das heißt, wir halten mal fest, wenn wir uns auf den Live-Pay-TV-Bereich oder auf den Live-Bereich beschränken, dann haben wir einen neuen Player, das ist Eurosport. Es ist noch nicht genau klar, wie sich das für den Konsumenten auswirken wird. Im besten Fall bleibt es für viele quasi in ihrem Abonnement enthalten. Und wir haben Sky, die sich ein zusätzliches Spiel jeden Montagabend in der zweiten Liga geholt haben. Das heißt, im Live-Bereich Sport1 der große Verlierer, Christoph.
Absolut. Also, Sport1 hat jetzt anders als bisher eben keinen Fixpunkt mehr, sprich das Montagsspiel, das man ja lange Jahre etabliert hatte. Und schon zu Zeiten, als es sonst fast keine zweite Liga im Fernsehen lief, schon gar nicht live, gab es das Montagsspiel live damals noch im DSF. Und das verliert man jetzt. Letztendlich war das ja oftmals auch schon der Aufhänger für andere Formate. Die Spieltagsanalyse, die dann danach kam, da wird man sich ein enormes Problem mit ins Haus holen, dass nunmehr dieses Spiel weg ist und man nicht mehr weitere Werbung für andere Formate bieten kann.
Das alles wird ja seinen Preis gehabt haben. Ihr habt es schon angedeutet, dass das nicht gerade transparent ist. Klar, das würde ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht wollen, wenn ich da mehrere hundert Millionen in Rechte stecke. Wir haben im Tribünengespräch ja schon besprochen, dass sich das eigentlich nie refinanziert. Kai, Sky wird, so kolportiert man, ordentlich in die Tasche greifen müssen für das, was sie sich jetzt für die Saisons 2017 bis 2021 gesichert haben. Was sind denn da so die Summen, über die man spricht?
Am einfachsten kann man über die durchschnittlichen Summen reden, die da im Laufe der vier Jahre gezahlt werden. In der aktuellen Rechteperiode über vier Jahre sind das 485 Millionen Euro. Das steigt an auf 876 Millionen Euro in einer Vierjahresperiode ab Sommer 2017. Also nicht ganz eine Verdoppelung, sondern gefühlt 80 Prozent oder so ähnlich. Das Ganze ist etwas komplizierter zu rechnen, denn das sind halt Durchschnittspreise. Tatsächlich ist es so, dass die rechten Preise eher gestaffelt gezahlt werden. Das heißt, man beginnt im ersten Jahr mit einer vergleichsweise niedrigen Summe, um dann letztendlich das Jahr für Jahr raufzusetzen, bis es dann zur höchsten Summe im vierten Jahr kommt. Was diese gesamte Verwertung der nationalen Medienrechtsverwertung angeht, so wird die Zahl komplettiert, dass im ersten Jahr für die DFL dabei 1,05 Milliarden Euro pro Saison rauspringen. Das steigt dann bis zum vierten Jahr auf 1,25 Milliarden Euro pro Saison an. Im Laufe dieser vier Jahre fallen dann sozusagen 200 Millionen Euro Mehreinnahmen an gestaffelte Billare.
Das sind schon wahnsinnige Summen. Aber da stellt sich mir die Frage, Christoph, gibt es eine Welt, die du dir vorstellen kannst, in der Sky-Kunden in Zukunft nicht mehr zahlen werden müssen?
Also, ganz sicher nicht. Man muss sich ganz einfach mal anschauen, erstens mal, was passiert hier bei uns gerade. Es ist schon die nächste Preiserhöhung angekündigt bei Sky. Das heißt, es wird auch an die Bestandsgründe rangehen. Und letztendlich, man muss sich einfach nur anschauen, was in Großbritannien passiert ist. Da sind die entsprechenden Abo-Preise regelmäßig angehoben worden. Das ist, sage ich jetzt mal, nicht nur absolut im Bereich des Möglichen, das ist so sicher wie das Armen in der Kirche, dass Sky ab sofort regelmäßig an der Preisschraube drehen wird. Das ist ganz klar.
Wobei es interessant sein wird, ob sie diesen Kurs werden durchhalten können. Weil es gibt teilweise bei den internationalen Pay-TV-Stationen auch gegensätzliche Bewegungen. Weil gesehen wird, dass die Zuschauer nicht willens sind, so ganz große Pakete zu zahlen und deswegen hohe monatliche Abo-Kosten sich an die Backe zu kleben. ESPN oder in Frankreich zum Beispiel Kanal Plus überlegen, ihre Abo zu verschlanken, kleinere Abo-Pakete anzubieten und dadurch dann auch niedrigere Abo-Einnahmen zu erzielen. Teilweise läuft das dann auch über den Weg, dass man zum Beispiel Alternativen über den Online-Weg anbietet, wie zum Beispiel dann auch in Großbritannien Tagestickets, Wochentickets oder Mondattickets, die im Sportbereich angeboten werden. Sky Deutschland will diese dann auch demnächst einführen ab der kommenden Bundesligasaison. Also die Vielfalt an Abo-Angeboten, die wird wachsen und mal sehen, ob dann auch andere Abo-Pakete geschnürt werden. Also wenn man sich die Entwicklung der Abonnentenzahlen bei Sky anguckt, so wird man die nächsten zwei, drei Quartale abwarten müssen. Derzeit sieht es ein bisschen aus, als würde das Wachstum so ein bisschen schwächer werden. Seit drei Quartalen gibt es von Quartal zu Quartal ein immer niedrigeres Wachstum. Wird man sehen müssen, wenn die Tendenz weitergeht, deutet sich da vielleicht an, dass der deutsche Markt gesächtig ist oder zumindest nicht willens ist, die Preise zu zahlen.
Okay, also wir dürfen gespannt sein. Allerdings bei einer fast Verdopplung der Rechte können die Fußball-Fans da draußen nicht davon ausgehen per se, dass sie für denselben Abo-Preis wie jetzt die Live-Spiele werden sehen können. Jetzt haben wir den Live-Bereich damit im Pay-TV-Bereich durch und wir haben schon kurz angesprochen, es wird aber auch weiter einige wenige Spiele im Free-TV zu sehen geben, Christoph, und die in Zukunft nicht mehr bei der ARD, sondern beim ZDF. Welche Spiele sind das nochmal?
Genau, also das ist jetzt das Eröffnungsspiel, also sprich am ersten Spieltag das erste Freitagsspiel. Dann ein Spiel am 17. Spieltag, das ist der letzte Hinrundenspieltag. Auch dort steht es zu vermuten und danach allem, was man hört, ist es auch ein Freitagsspiel. Und dann auch am ersten Rückrundenspieltag, also am 18. Spieltag, ein weiteres Freitagsspiel. Dazu kommt dann eben noch der Super Cup und die Relegation zwischen der 2. und der 3. Liga. Eben nicht mehr die Relegation zwischen der 1. und der 2. Liga, aber eben das sind die Spiele, die in dem Paket sind, die das ZDF gekauft hat.
Okay, dann haben wir damit den Live-Bereich gut durchexerziert. Ich glaube, jetzt haben alle eine Vorstellung davon, was auf uns zukommt. Ab 2017, 2018 lasst man noch über die rechte Pakete für die zeitversetzte Verwertung sprechen. Also sprich, ich sag mal jetzt, Hashtag Sportschau, Hashtag aktuelle Sportsstudio. Darunter kann man es sich am besten vorstellen. Was hat sich da getan, Kai?
Also die ganz großen Statthalter wie ARD und ZDF sind geblieben. Das heißt, die ARD behält ihre Samstags Sportschau. Die ARD behält auch ihre Sonntags Sportschau in den dritten Programm. Das hat man nicht zwingend so erwartet, weil dann doch damit gerechnet worden ist, dass RTL stärker gegenhält und dass die ARD sich finanziell nicht mehr beide Angebote leisten wird. Das ZDF behält seine Sportstudio-Verwertung, unter anderem mit dem Topspiel um 18.30 Uhr, das dann als Highlight gebracht werden darf. Und dann fängt es an, etwas anders zu werden. Bei Sport 1 ist eigentlich nur noch ein Paket übrig geblieben, nämlich die Zweitverwertung am Sonntag zwischen 6 Uhr und 15 Uhr. Alles andere ist erstmal nicht da. Weder die Freitags-Zweitverwertung noch die Verwertung am Sonntagabend ist erstmal nicht da. Diese beiden Pakete, sowohl Freitag als auch Sonntag, ist nicht vergeben worden. Ebenfalls ist ein neues Highlight-Paket, das für den Montagabend vorgesehen ist. Wenn man jetzt hier darüber diskutiert, worüber die Geschichte der DFL heute erfolgreich ausgegangen ist, was den Verkauf der Pakete angeht, so bleibt dann doch der Markelhaft, dass die DFL zwei Pakete schlichtweg nicht los geworden ist, weil nicht der Preis geboten worden ist, den die DFL dafür erwartet hatte. Das ist ein Markel, den die DFL nicht ganz so hört, der auch nicht so ganz in Forderung stand, aber den ich schon interessant fand, weil das eigentlich bislang Geschichten waren, die man nur aus Spanien und Italien kannte, dass dort Pakete schlichtweg nicht einem Mann gebracht werden können.
Und es hat ja aus Fansicht schon eine Konsequenz, weil es stand, jetzt kann ich nicht am Freitag schon eine Zusammenfassung des Freitagsspiels sehen, sondern müsste damit bis zur Sportschau warten.
War das Freitagsspiel der Bundesliga nicht eh erst in der Sportschau dran? Ich meine, dass Sport 1 am Freitag nur die Zweitliga-Heilharz weislang gezeigt hätte.
Genau. Aber jetzt mit dem Paket, mit dem was nicht vergeben wurde, damit waren die Zweitliga-Verwertungen gemeint. Man sieht, ich werde auch durcheinander geworfen von diesen Paketen.
Im Moment gibt es noch keine zweite Liga im Freitag. Das ist aber auch ganz klar das Ergebnis. Ich war ja heute in Frankfurt bei der Präsentation. Da hörte man das ein oder andere Stöhnen, wie Christian Seifert gesagt hat, dass dieses Paket wurde nicht vergeben. Alle sagten, was? Das ist eine große Verwunderung. Damit ist nicht gerechnet worden. Das ist schon ein Ereignis, wo man sich fragen muss, wie konnte das passieren? Was sind die Hintergründe dessen? Da gibt es natürlich die einen oder anderen Gerüchte, warum das so war. Da muss man mal gucken, was die nächsten Tage ergeben.
Es ist offensichtlich, dass Sport 1, die buchte auf diese Pakete, nicht genügend geboten hat. Das kann man dann auch erst mal feststellen, was ein weiterer Minuspunkt ist in der Rechnung, die man für Sport 1 bei der Vergabe dieser Rechteperiode erst mal aufsetzen muss. Das Ganze unter Vorbehalt, weil diese beiden Pakete noch nicht vergeben sind. Sie sollen noch mal ausgeschrieben werden, vergeben werden. Und vielleicht schaut sich Sport 1 an, was sie derzeit haben, und stellt fest, okay, vielleicht schlagen wir doch noch mal oben drauf.
Gleichzeitig ist es ja aber auch ein Signal an mögliche andere Interessenten. Also wenn ich jetzt einfach davon ausgehe, es gab noch Marktteilnehmer, die an diesem Bieterverfahren teilgenommen haben, die bisher nichts bekommen haben, von denen wir nichts wissen, dann ist das an die auch das Signal. Also in dem Bereich haben wir kein Angebot bekommen, was so hoch war, dass wir es annehmen mussten. Das hätte ja auch passieren können. Und es war auch nicht so hoch, dass wir es annehmen wollten. Und deswegen kann ich damit ja auch den Bieterdruck auf Sport 1 erhöhen.
Naja, so sonnellig attraktiv sind jetzt so ein Neueinsteiger diese Pakete nicht. Also wir gehen jetzt über die Zusammenfassung der zweiten Liga, der Freitagsspiele und der Sonntagsspiele. Und wir reden von einem neuen Zusammenfassungs-Slot am Montagabend, mit dem man alle Spiele der Bundesliga und alle Spiele der zweiten Liga zusammenfassen kann. Gut, dieses Montagspaket ist vielleicht nicht schlecht für einen Neueinsteiger, aber der redaktionelle Aufwand wäre natürlich auch relativ hoch, weil man natürlich alle 18 Spiele eines Bundesligaspieltages abdecken müsste.
Also es ist nicht so attraktiv, sondern gut. Bisschen Gemeinde an alle Zweitliga-Fans da draußen, aber wir sind ja nicht hier, um euch zu pleasen. So ist die Lage gerade. Das heißt, diese beiden Pakete sind noch offen. Stand jetzt wissen wir nicht, wo die zweite Liga im FreeTV stattfinden wird. Das wird sich jetzt in der Zukunft ergeben. Und dann gibt es noch ein Paket, das Paket namens O oder Null. Das ist die Frage, wie man das interpretiert. Das sind Highlight-Clips, die man ausspielen darf. Entweder über eine Pay-Variante oder über eine Free-Variante. 40 Minuten nach Abpfiff. Wer hat sich dieses Paket geholt und was ist damit zu erwarten, Christoph?
Ja, also Erwerber ist die sagenumworbende Komponente, von der alle gesagt haben, die werden jetzt bei dieser Ausschreibung richtig reinbuttern. Und zwar Perform. Der sportrechte Händler bzw. der Neueinsteiger, der große Player, der schon in den letzten Wochen und Monaten Rechte gesammelt hat, alles gekauft hat, was bei drei nicht auf den Bäumen war, unter anderem die Premier League. Der hat sich jetzt auch in die Bundesliga eingekauft, allerdings nicht so, wie es von vielen Marktteilnehmern und Beobachtern vermutet worden ist, mit einem Live-Paket, sondern eben nur in Anführungszeichen mit diesem Highlight-Paket, was vorher unter anderem bei Axel Springer lag, mit dem das Bild-Plus-Angebot aufgepeppt worden ist.
Aufgepeppt oder lebeneignet, je nachdem, wie man das interpretieren möchte.
Oder auch nicht. Der Axel Springer-Verlag hat ja im Vorfeld kommuniziert, ja, war nicht so der Bringer.
Jetzt hat sich das performen geholt, da dürfen wir gespannt sein. Es wird da wohl eine eigene Plattform geben. Kai, du hattest da einiges in deinem Blog drüber geschrieben.
Richtig, die wird DASN heißen oder DESSEN oder so. Sie wird eine internationale Plattform sein. Sie wird zuerst in Japan starten und dann in Deutschland, Österreich und ich glaube, Spals. Es gab heute das Gerücht, dass Perform ganz groß in die J-League für seine Plattform in Japan einsteigt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dazu schon eine offizielle Meldung gab. Es heute geht davon über 500 Millionen Dollar. Aber wie gesagt, das war erst mal nur ein nicht verifiziertes Gerücht. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob sich das inzwischen bewahrheitet hat.
Aber die Zeit drängt ja langsam für Perform. Sie haben ja auch die Premier League-Rechte. In ein paar Wochen geht die Premier League ja schon wieder los.
Gut, gucken wir mal, was da kommt. Man munkelt vom Netflix des Sports. Wir werden uns überraschen lassen. Damit hätten wir die aktuelle Rechtevergabe skizziert. Ich habe auch die Summen schon genannt. Wir haben grob darüber gesprochen. Jetzt hätte ich gerne von euch beiden Total-Experten eine allgemeine Einschätzung. Christoph, was sind deine Gedanken zu dieser Rechtevergabe?
Ja, einen Punkt haben wir noch vergessen. Die Radiorechte. Die Podcast-Rechte sind weniger spektakulär. Die sind bei der ARD geblieben. Also wer am Samstagnachmittag sein Auto wächt, kann weiter dabei aus dem Autoradio die Konferenz hören. Aber wo es eine Neuerung gab, und das ist irgendwie auch ein Treppenwitz, ist bei den Internet-Rechten. Und zwar hat die jetzt nicht mehr Sport1 wie vorher für Sport1 FM, sondern Amazon. Und die haben auch schon bekannt gegeben, dass sie diese Rechte im Wege von Prime Music ausnutzen werden, was letztendlich zu zwei Dingen führt. Das eine ist, Sport1 FM steht ohne ihr wichtigstes Recht da und droht, dasselbe Schicksal wie 9011 zu erleiden. Der Sender dem Sport1 FM schon das Licht ausgeknipst hat. Und jetzt droht Sport1 FM dasselbe. Das andere ist, die Bundesliga im Internet, also sprich halt eben über Apps, geht jetzt in den Pay-Bereich. Weil letztendlich Prime Music kostet Geld. Das ist auch schon eine Entwicklung. Und vor allem tritt hier mit Amazon ein internationaler Player auf das Paket, von dem viele überlegt hatten, meinen die es wirklich ernst? Was planen die? Und die sind nun wirklich doch ernsthaft reingegangen. Nicht mit Live-Rechten, wo es auch Gerüchte gab, dass sie auch irgendwie Live-Rechte mitgeboten haben, aber auf jeden Fall erfolgreich bei diesen Rechten. Da haben wir noch viel Spaß mit denen bei den nächsten Ausschreibungen.
Gut, aber die nächsten Ausschreibungen sind ja auch im Jahr 2021 oder 2020 wahrscheinlich so. Da hoffe ich dann auch, dass wir ein paar neue Player noch mit dabei haben, dass sich bis dahin ein bisschen was entwickelt hat. Ich hätte jetzt aber gesagt, als jemand, der keine Quoten von Sport 1 FM kennt und der das selbst ehrlich gesagt seitdem ich Skyhabe überhaupt nicht mehr verwende, hätte ich gesagt, das stelle ich mir nicht als besonders großes Paket vor, diese Audioübertragungsrechte übers Internet. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass es jetzt so massentauglich ist. Liege ich da komplett daneben, Christoph?
Also, ich weiß nicht, wie es jetzt letztendlich sich entwickeln wird, dadurch, dass es ein Pay-Angebot wird. Bisher war es immer eine Alternative zu einem kostenpflichtigen Angebot, sprich Skyh, derjenige, der sich kein Skyh leisten wollte oder konnte, aber dem dann die ARD-Konferenz im Radio zu wenig Fußball war, oder halt eben der dann doch lieber nur seinen Verein hören wollte, für den gab es eben diese wirklich günstige, sprich kostenlose Variante Sport 1 FM. Das fällt jetzt weg. Amazon macht da draußen natürlich eher so ein bisschen einen Gemichtwarenladen, weil letztendlich da kann man dann alles Mögliche kaufen, dann gibt es eben Amazon Instant Video und dann eben nunmehr bei Prime Music auch die Bundesliga. Also es fällt mir auch schwer, das ein bisschen einschätzen zu können, aber ich gehe dann auch davon aus, dass es für Amazon ein strategisches Investment war, um für die nächsten Perioden dann den Fuß in die Tür zu bekommen.
Und ergibt das für dich Kai aus Sicht der DFL überhaupt Sinn? Denn vor der Argumentationslinie, wie Christoph es jetzt beschrieben hat, nämlich als Alternative zu allen Pay-Angeboten und ein bisschen mehr Audio-Content, Live-Content, ist es ja dann schon wichtig, wenn ich jetzt einfach nur vom Fan aus denke.
Ich traue Christian Seifert nicht unbedingt die Perspektive eines Fans zu, oder zumindest sehr viel Empathie dafür. Wie Christoph sagte, das Radio Recht fällt aus. Man darf ja nicht vergessen, dass diese Übertragung, diese Streams von Sportanz.fm, glaube ich ja auch, auf bundesliga.de in Anführungszeichen gespiegelt wurden. Und damit hat auch bundesliga.de, also die DFL-eigene Website, zum ersten Mal seit Jahren, dann ab 2017, kein eigenes Audioangebot mehr. Ich bin auch gespannt, wie Amazon das produziert, ob sie sich dann letztendlich der Bordmittel von Platzamedia schrägstrich Sport1 bedienen werden, sodass man letztendlich wieder die gleichen Kommentatoren hören wird. Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein weltbewegendes Recht ist, weil die Hoffnung, die man mit Sport1 FM im ersten Jahr gehabt hatte, dass man damit zum ersten Mal in Deutschland ein Sportradio mit etablieren könnte, haben sich einfach nicht erfüllt. Ab dem zweiten Jahr hat man einfach gnadenlos die Kosten runtergefahren und ein Billigprogramm angeboten, das vor allen Dingen von den Fußballvertragungen nicht nur der Bundesliga, sondern auch von anderen Wettbewerben lebte. Ich glaube, der Verlust ist nicht allzu groß. Auch wenn Sport1 sich gerne als 360-Grad-Plattform bewirbt, dann sind es jetzt nur 350 Grad.
Gut. Und nachdem ihr mich jetzt schon eingefangen habt, ich wollte das als Rauschmeister bringen mit Amazon noch, Christoph, kannst du uns jetzt vielleicht deine Gedanken zu dieser TV-Rechte-Vergabe mitteilen?
Ja, also im Endeffekt muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, für den Fan hätte es deutlich schlimmer kommen können. Für Sky hätte es deutlich schlimmer kommen können. Und für die Liga hätte es auch deutlich schlimmer, aber auch meiner Meinung nach noch ein bisschen besser kommen können. Das Ergebnis wird von allen Beteiligten hochgejubelt. Die Stimmen sind durchweg positiv. Die Signalmarke von der 1 Milliarde pro Saison hat man geknackt. Das ist das Wichtige gewesen. Aber eben, wie Kai schon gesagt hat, wir sind am unteren Ende des vorgegebenen Korridors gelandet. Aber letztendlich, für den Fan muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, er kriegt weiterhin das meiste mit einem Abo, wenn nicht sogar alles, solange sich Sky und Eurosport einig sind. Und im Free-TV gibt es auch noch ein paar Spiele, allerdings deutlich weniger. Das muss man ganz klar sagen. Es gibt einen großen Verlierer im Moment, das ist Sport1. Da muss man abwarten, was passiert mit den anderen, noch nicht vergebenen Rechten. Wobei ich auch irgendwie, mir fehlt die Fantasie, da großartige Konkurrenz drum zu sehen. Aber letztendlich, man hat das Montagsspiel verloren. Ein anderer Teilweise-Verlierer, auch wenn es nicht auf den ersten Blick so aussieht, ist für mich auch noch die ARD. Auch wenn es nur wenige Spiele waren, die man jetzt verloren hat. Aber jetzt hat man abseits des DFB-Pokals, nachdem man schon die Nationalmannschaftsrechte verloren hat, keinen erstklassigen Fußball mehr im Programm. Das finde ich schon heftig für die ARD. Die nun wirklich nur wegen Kroninieren alle zwei Jahre und DFB-Pokal jetzt noch ihre Live-Kommentatoren beschäftigen darf. Aber sonst im Endergebnis für den Fan ist es mit Sicherheit eigentlich eine Auktion so, der sehr viel besser hätte es dann noch nicht sein können.
Kai, welche Ergänzungen hast du dazu?
Bei aller Spekulation, die es im Vorfeld gegeben hat, hat es dann letztendlich doch relativ wenig Bewegung gegeben. Wir haben es mit sehr vielen alten, bekannten Playern zu tun. Und das ganze Rumgehühner von Seiten des Kartellamtes mit dieser No-Single-Buy-Rules und Stärkung der Innovationsfreude hat sich letztendlich überhaupt nicht verwirklicht. Wenn ich mir so die Zusammenstellung angucke, wer was sendet, sieht das für mich üblich so aus, als würde es quasi wie gewohnt weitergehen, mehr oder weniger.
Glaubst du, dass das auch ein Deal war? Man könnte sich ja schon vorstellen, dass Sky sich mal mit Eurosport an den Tisch gesetzt hat und gesagt hat, wir wollen nicht dieses zweite Paket da los treten, wenn wir alle Live-Rechte haben. Gleichzeitig haben wir euch über Satellit bei uns ja quasi schon eingepreist. Ist sowas denkbar?
Also das war ja im Grunde genommen meine Ausgangsthese seit Wochen, ehe sich dann innerhalb der letzten zwei Wochen immer mehr Gerüchte aufkamen, dass es eher in Richtung Telekom oder Vodafone oder vielleicht doch per Forum gehen würde. Aber letztendlich ist es meine Ausgangsthese gewesen, die ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, vor sechs Monaten in den Raum geschmissen habe, weil Eurosport und Sky zwei Player sind, die über Verträge, über eine funktionierende Geschäftsbeziehung verfügen. Sky kann immer noch von sich behaupten, hey, Eurosport 2 HD, wie er sagt, liegt nur exklusiv auf unserer Plattform. Also auch das lässt sich einigermaßen brav vermarkten. Offiziell werden sie es nie zugeben dürfen, dass es da möglicherweise Gespräche gab. Hey, beide sind München beheimatet. Dann trifft man sich bei Lidl in der Obstabteilung. Hey, du hier.
Die beiden CEOs, genau, das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen. Okay, Entschuldigung, mit diesem Einschub habe ich dich unterbrochen. Was wolltest du uns noch sagen?
Ähm, nee, eigentlich war es das schon große Modus. Aus Sicht des High-End-Fans oder aus Sicht des Kartellamtes, das sich diese ganz große Innovationsfreude erhofft hat, die sehe ich jetzt gerade bei diesem Tableau, wie sich das ergeben hat, eigentlich nicht. Es riecht so ein bisschen nach vier Jahren, mehr oder weniger genauso weiter, wie es bislang ist. Und ja, das finde ich ein bisschen schade. Ich hätte mir da so ein bisschen mehr Fantasie erwünscht.
Gut, dann bleibt mir nichts weiter, als euch beiden zu danken. Vielen Dank an Kai Pahl, den Ed Dogfood auf Twitter. Ihr kennt ihn von alles außer sport.de. Und vielen Dank an Christoph Anheuser auf Twitter. Ed, R, C, unterstrich, K, H. Und jetzt schauen wir mal, wie dann die TV-Gelder verteilt werden. Das ist ja ein ganz anderes Thema. Das haben wir auch im Tribünengespräch angesprochen. Das könnt ihr euch vielleicht noch mal anhören, wenn es euch interessiert. Und ansonsten warten wir, was da kommt. Und das war dann unser erster Rasenfunk-Kurzpass.